as Jazmin gold from Buffalo Nia down he
goes what a way to kick off the decades
you saw that right Ryan Seacrest took a
major fall during Tuesday's live with
Kelly and Ryan tumbling backwards and
out of his chair and to think it was all
over a balloon it all started when the
45 year old TV personality and his
co-host Kelly Ripa were beginning their
20/20 travel trivia segment Ryan became
a little too vacinated by the gold shiny
object falling from the ceiling that
eventually caused him to hit the floor
Kelly panicked rushing to her co-host
site to make sure he was okay but Ryan
popped right back up as if nothing
happened the adrenaline is coursing
through you but very strange well
according to Ryan he's fine he even
posted a clip of the tumble to his
Instagram and hilariously wrote in the
caption first fumble of the new season
hope I make the playoffs that's a great
moment but interestingly it's not the
only recent tumble Ryan's been a part of
fresh off hosting duties for Dick
Clark's New Year's rockin Eve
Ryan watched as rapper post Malone fell
off the stage and into the audience but
thankfully the fall didn't seem to
affect posties mood as he was seen
smiling while being helped back up on to
the stage but back to Ryan no doubt he's
one of the busiest guys in showbiz he
told us in July what he does when he's
not working I haven't thought about it
yet but I should start focusing on it
you're gonna have to face retirement
soon I may be ready some golf
no not golf golf isn't for me no but
something without a watch or a clock oh
that's impossible then we're watching
around my thumb do you meditate do yoga
Pilates I do a little bit of all of it I
need to do more of all of it
[Music]